hoy vamos a estar hablando del síndrome
del ovario poliquístico o como le dicen
que sí o vas yo soy un obstetra
ginecóloga y voy a estar reaccionando al
vídeo de ni kirchner comer ya el
síndrome de ovario poliquístico también
llamado ps o ese es un desequilibrio de
las hormonas sexuales femeninas
los ovarios forman parte del sistema
reproductor femenino
junto con las trompas de falopio
el útero
y la vagina
sus ovarios contienen sus óvulos
estos óvulos son inmaduros y se
almacenan en pequeñas estructuras tiene
este líquido llamadas folículos
la glándula pituitaria situada en la
base del cerebro produce hormonas que
dirigen la función de sus ovarios
cada mes la glándula pituitaria secreta
la hormona estimulante del folículo o
efe sh y la hormona luteinizante lh
hacia el torrente sanguíneo
después de que estas hormonas llegan a
los ovarios varios cientos de óvulos
inmaduros comienzan a madurar
incrementando el tamaño de los folículos
voy a para el vídeo y el rapidito porque
me está encantando como están enseñando
todo aquí está enseñando todo el proceso
del ciclo menstrual cómo estás
relacionado a los ovarios y el cerebro y
explicando todas las hormonas porque es
súper importante porque con pesce efe
todo esto cambia a medida que los óvulos
maduran los folículos secretan estrógeno
la principal hormona sexual femenina una
vez que la cantidad de estrógeno en la
sangre alcanza un cierto nivel
la pituitaria envía una gran cantidad de
hormona luteinizante a los ovarios
haciendo que el folículo más maduro se
abra y libere su óvulo en un proceso
llamado ovulación
el óvulo liberado viaja por la trompa de
falopio donde espera la fertilización
con el tiempo los folículos inmaduros y
los óvulos restantes se disuelven
si el óvulo no es fecundado el óvulo y
el revestimiento del útero se desprende
durante el siguiente periodo menstrual
es que me encanta cómo está explicando a
todo muy bien ahora creo que van a
empezar a explicar cómo todo esto cambia
en alguien que tenga deseo excel es bien
importante porque antes de poder
entender exactamente lo que está pasando
durante el pcf hay que entender primero
lo que es normal si usted padece del
síndrome de ovario poliquístico su
glándula pituitaria puede liberar altas
cantidades anormales de hormona
luteinizante hacia el torrente sanguíneo
antes que se me olvide con una escucha
que una condición médica es un síndrome
eso significa que está afectando
diferentes partes del cuerpo diferentes
órganos como ya escuchamos este proceso
como tal no es solamente de los ovarios
también tiene que ver con las hormonas
del cerebro los ovarios los tubos de
falopio y también la matriz y la vamos a
ver que también afecta otros órganos te
iniciante hacia el torrente sanguíneo
lo que altera su ciclo menstrual normal
como consecuencia los folículos no
maduran y la ovulación no ocurre lo que
puede llevar a la infertilidad
algunos de los folículos inmaduros no se
disuelven y permanecen como sacos llenos
de lilly estos quistes que se quedan en
los ovarios es lo que nosotros podemos
ver en un ultrasonido todos vemos el
ovario y tienes un quiste chiquito en
alrededor de todo el ovario como
nosotros vemos eso en ultrasonido lo
primero que pensamos es pc o efe además
el médico puede encontrar que su sangre
tiene niveles altos de insulina una
hormona producida por el páncreas
el exceso de insulina en combinación con
altos niveles de hormona luteinizante
puede conducir a un exceso de producción
de una hormona masculina llamada
testosterona en los ovarios los altos
niveles anormales de testosterona
detienen la ovulación lo que puede
llevar a la infertilidad
nos estaban explicando en el vídeo las
mujeres que tienen peces se pueden tener
altos niveles de insulina por esto estas
mujeres están en el acto riesgo de que
le de diabetes tipo 2 los altos niveles
de testosterona también causan muchas de
las características físicas asociadas al
síndrome de ovario poliquístico
tales como el acné y el crecimiento
anormal de vello
padecer del síndrome de ovario
poliquístico aumenta el riesgo de
diabetes tipo 2 debido a un exceso de
insulina y resistencia a la misma
enfermedades del corazón presión
arterial alta
anormalidades de colesterol en la sangre
y cáncer de endometrio como dije esto es
un síndrome afecta muchos diferentes
órganos en muchos sistemas en el cuerpo
puesto que no hay cura para el síndrome
de ovario poliquístico el médico puede
recomendar uno o más medicamentos para
tratar sus síntomas tales como los
anticonceptivos hormonales que aparte de
prevenir el embarazo también regulan el
ciclo menstrual y reducen la producción
de testosterona en los ovarios
los medicamentos antiandrogénicos que
reducen el crecimiento anormal de vello
y acné los medicamentos para la diabetes
tales como la met morfina que reducen
los niveles de insulina y regula el
ciclo
y los medicamentos para la fertilidad
que estimulan la ovulación por lo que
puede quedar embarazada
ahora rapidito quiero explicar un
poquito más acerca de la fertilidad que
la mujer tiene pss no necesariamente
significa que tiene que tomar medicinas
de fertilidad o para ayudarla a quedar
embarazada todo caso es diferente si
tiene peso ese es importante que hable
con su médico a ver lo que sea necesario
para ti si desea quedar embarazada y los
medicamentos para la fertilidad no han
tenido éxito en el restablecimiento de
la ovulación el médico puede recomendar
la incisión ovárica laparoscópica
durante el procedimiento
el cirujano insertará una pequeña aguja
dentro del ovario y usará una corriente
eléctrica para destruir las pequeñas
áreas de tejido ovárico
donde se produce la testosterona
con el tiempo la producción de
testosterona disminuye y puede ocurrir
la ovulación
como siempre me encantó el vídeo creo
que lo explicaron súper bien a mí me
gusta aprender mucho con vídeos con
imágenes y estos son perfectos yo espero
que hayan aprendido un poquito más
acerca del pcv ese tratamiento y
opciones que tienen este vídeo ha sido
una colaboración entre new y es tener
convivía y mi canal de youtube a dívar
en ti en mi canal de youtube yo ha
creado un espacio donde yo puedo hablar
sobre muchos temas que tienen que ver
con la salud de la mujer si me quieren
seguir en mi canal de youtube les voy a
dejar un link en la descripción abajo
verdad que me encanta haciendo estos
vídeos reaccionando a esta animación
porque es tan brutal espero que les haya
gustado el vídeo y espero que tengan un
lindo día nos vemos en el próximo bye